et enfin ce journal avec la série qui
vient de s'achever à damas une
conférence internationale sur le retour
des réfugiés syriens dans leur pays
présents à cette conférence organisée
sous l'égide de la russie le ligand mais
également l'irak elle s'achète un défi
la durée du conflit en 2011 plus de cinq
millions et demi de personnes ont fui la
syrie y voyez les précisions de notre
envoyé spécial à damas antoine guillon
dans le cadre de la conférence
internationale sur le retour de réfugiés
nous avons pu accéder à un camp de
réfugiés en banlieue de damas où est
organisé par le ministère la défense
russe une distribution d' aide
humanitaire alors voyons voir un petit
peu ce qu'on peut trouver dans ces
paquets donc de l'aide alimentaire du
riz des conserves et voilà des céréales
la russie dépense environ 150 millions
de dollars par an pour différents
programmes d' aide aux peuples syrien au
moins 150 millions
il est important de comprendre que
l'aide humanitaire ira bien évidemment
peuple syrien mais aujourd'hui il est
essentiel de rétablir les
infrastructures sociales les hôpitaux
les écoles les logements les routes
créer des emplois l'aide humanitaire
peut soutenir les gens immédiatement
mais il est important de réunir les
conditions pour qu'ils puissent vivre et
travailler indépendamment de cette aide
humanitaire
nous sommes ravis d'être avec le peuple
syrien et nous resterons avec le peuple
syrien
comme on peut s'y attendre de nos
endroits densément peuplées comme ici là
que vides n'épargne pas les camps de
réfugiés syriens nous avons pu nous
entretenir avec des médecins du camp
afin de parler de la situation sanitaire
sur place une conférence internationale
sur le secours de la fédération de
russie vis-à-vis des civils syriens se
tient ces jours-ci nous représentons
l'équipe médicale dont conjointement
avec le ministère russe de la santé
des collègues syriens et des médecins on
effectue un diagnostic sur les adultes
les enfants
nous dépistons également le coronavirus
à l'aide des test express comme dans le
reste de la syrie la population du camp
est très jeune
aussi quand une compétition de football
est organisé c'est un événement la
plupart de ces enfants n'ont connu que
cette vie cette vie de réfugié cette vie
de déplacés reste à espérer pour eux et
pour l'avenir de la syrie 15 jours ils
connaîtront enfin une vie normale